thousands of tons of rice seeds will
soon be leaving South Korea and heading
to African countries as part of an
initiative which aims to boost rice
production on the continent
firstly South Korea and Africa have an
important food resource in common South
Korea is also the only country that has
managed to become self-sufficient in
term of rice production in a very short
period of time
Senegal The Gambia Guinea Ghana Cameroon
Uganda Kenya and guinea bissau have
signed onto the project which will
distribute quality rice seeds that are
high yielding and more resistant to
pests and disease
Seoul will also Share technology with
partner countries to help develop
farming infrastructure
our expectations are very very high and
and that's because
Korea has been through this just like
Africa is going through it now
um 50 years ago there was food
insecurity or food in sufficiency in
Korea or around
this is exactly what we have today in
most African countries the seeds are
expected to yield harvests up to three
times larger than local varietals and
have been developed to adapt to weather
conditions in the participating
countries
the program aims to distribute more than
9 000 tons of rice seed each year by
2027. South Korea's Ministry of
Agriculture food and Rural Affairs says
that should produce enough rice to feed
30 million people each year a un report
released in July warned of an increase
in global hunger since 2019 with Africa
being the worst affected continent
researchers say initiatives like this
can help to manage Global Food Supplies
as climate change takes its toll on
farming we should also thanks of the
variety of rice that can for example can
adapt with climate change can end up
with high temperature can add up with
high salt in the water or something like
that in the future we shoot things also
about that long term the plan is for
these countries to become
self-sufficient in rice production which
project organizers say will help
governments manage future food security
challenges Jessica Washington Al Jazeera
ansong South Korea